SATELLITE CONSPIRACY THEORY.
SO IT IS VERY INTERESTING CLAIM
FROM MARK MEADOWS.
>> INDEED.
THANKS SO MUCH.
LET'S DISCUSS.
SO OBVIOUSLY TRUMP WANTS TO RUN
OUT THE CLOCK AND IT IS EXPECTED
REPUBLICANS COULD WIN THE HOUSE
IN A YEAR.
THAT WOULD BE THE HISTORICAL
NORM BECAUSE DEMOCRATS ARE IN
THE WHITE HOUSE AND REPUBLICANS
WOULD TAKE THE HOUSE.
IT IS SUCH A NARROW MAJORITY AS
IT IS.
THE THREE JUDGES ALL APPOINTED
BY DEMOCRATS JUST GAVE THEM A
LITTLE HELP.
>> A LITTLE MORE TIME.
THIS GOES BACK TO THE STRATEGY
THE FORMER PRESIDENT AND HIS
TEAM USED EVEN BACK TO 2019 WHEN
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDING WERE
GOING ON AND THEY WERE TRYING TO
PREVENT HIS THEN WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL FROM APPEARING BEFORE
CONGRESS.
THE PACE OF THESE DECISIONS IS
GOING TO BE KEY IN WHETHER OR
NOT ALL OF THESE DOCUMENTS, ALL
OF THIS INFORMATION THAT THE
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEE IS
LOOKING FOR ACTUALLY GETS TO SEE
THEM AT THIS POINT.
AS YOU SAID, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S STRATEGY HERE AND
HIS TEAM IS GOING TO BE TO GET
THIS STUCK IN LITIGATION AS LONG
AS YOU POSSIBLY CAN UNTIL THE
CLOCK RUNS OUT THE CLOCK RUNNING
OUT BEING AS YOU NOTED MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
YOU CAN ASSUME AFTER THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS AND IF REPUBLICANS
WERE TO TAKE OVER, AND RECLAIM A
MAJORITY THAT MIGHT BE THE END
OF THE LINE FOR THE JANUARY 6
COMMITTEE.
THE PACE IS GOING TO BE
FASCINATING BUT YOU CAN ALSO
LOOK BEFORE THIS DECISION TODAY
I BELIEVE IT ONLY TOOK 23 DAYS
FOR A RULING ON THIS CASE.
THAT IS A FASTER PACE THAN 2019
WHEN IT WAS TAKING MONTHS.
>> AND ATTORNEY GENERAL MERRICK
GARLAND AND THE U.S. ATTORNEY
JUST NAMED FOR THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA STILL HAVEN'T COME
FORWARD AND SAID WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO DO ABOUT STEVE BANNON
BEING HELD IN CRIMINAL CONTEMPT
OF CONGRESS FOR NOT COMPLYING.
IT SEEMS LIKE ALL THE OTHER
WITNESSES ARE WAITING TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENS THERE WHETHER THERE
IS GOING TO BE ANY SORT OF
PROSECUTION.
>> IT'S BAN REALLY LONG TIME
SINCE ANYONE FACED ANY CRIMINAL
REPERCUSSIONS FOR NOT COMPLYING
WITH A CONGRESSIONAL SUBPOENA.
RIGHT NOW THIS JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAS TO DECIDE WHAT IT
WANTS TO DO WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
JUST NOT WILLING TO COMPLY.
YOU KNOW, YOU TALKED ABOUT
NORMS.
IN THE PAST, PEOPLE WOULD
GENERALLY TRY TO WORK SOMETHING
OUT WITH CONGRESS.
THEY WOULDN'T JUST SAY, NO
BLATANTLY.
BUT THAT HASN'T BEEN THE CASE
WITH THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION
AND IT WORKED REALLY WELL FOR
THEM.
SO THEY'LL KEEP IT UP UNTIL THEY
FACE ACTUAL REPERCUSSIONS.
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN
ATTACKING LIZ CHENEY THE
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICAN FROM
WYOMING WHO HAS BEEN STANDING UP
AGAINST THE BIG LIE AND IS ON
THIS COMMITTEE.
TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT SHE SAID
ABOUT WHAT SHE IS HEARING FROM
FELLOW REPUBLICANS ABOUT HER
ACTIVITIES ON THE COMMITTEE.
>> PRIVATELY BEHIND THE SCENES
THERE ARE MANY, MANY REPUBLICANS
WHO SAY THANK YOU FOR WHAT
YOU'RE DOING.
WE WISH WE COULD BE MORE PUBLIC.
PEOPLE WHO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT IS SAYING IS
DANGEROUS AND NOT TRUE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL I'VE HEARD SIMILAR
THINGS FROM REPUBLICANS FOR
ABOUT FIVE YEARS.
WHEN IT COMES TO DONALD TRUMP IT
WOULD BE NICE IF SOME OF THEM
WERE TO STAND UP AND SPEAK IN
PUBLIC, BUT COURAGE SEEMS TO BE
IN SHORT SUPPLY.
>> SHE WAS ALSO ASKED IF SHE IS
NOT RULING OUT A 2024 BID.
SHE REPLIED I THINK IT IS GOING
TO BE A VERY IMPORTANT YEAR.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
I KNOW YOU ARE NOT A REPUBLICAN.
DO YOU THINK THERE IS A LANE FOR
LIZ CHENEY IN PRESIDENTIAL
POLITICS?
>> I DO.
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS WHO FEEL THEY DON'T
HAVE A HOME RIGHT NOW SO THEY
ARE LOOKING FOR SOMEPLACE TO GO.
I'M NOT SURE LIZ CHENEY IS GOING
TO BE THE HOME THEY MIGHT WANT
TO GEAR TOWARD.
I THINK THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY
IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY TO
REALLY DECIDE WHO THEY ARE GOING
TO BE AND IF THEY HAVE A
CANDIDATE THAT CAN DRAW AWAY
FROM THIS TRUMP IDOL THEY HAVE
RIGHT NOW AND REALLY BE
COMPETITIVE WITH THE MODERATE
VOTERS WE SAW A WEEK AGO IN
VIRGINIA, NOT WANTING TO GO WITH
BIDEN OR WHOEVER IS ON THE
TICKET FOR THE DEMOCRATS IN 2024
CHENEY MAY BE AN OPTION.
THERE MAY BE A LIST OF OTHERS AS
WELL
>> I JUST THINK IF ONE OF YOUR
TOP THREE ATTRIBUTES IS
ANTI-TRUMP, THAT THERE IS NOT
GOING TO BE AN AUDIENCE IN THE
REPUBLICAN PRIMARY.
>> MAYBE A LOT OF VOTERS BUT
SOME HAVE LEFT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY AND THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
BE VOTING IN THE REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY.
>> BUT TO HER POINT SHE IS
SAYING PEOPLE ARE SAYING IT
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
WHEN YOU GO INTO YOUR BALLOT BOX
YOU DON'T KNOW WHO YOU'LL VOTE
FOR.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING,
LIKE AN ANTI-TRUMP TICKET IS
PROBABLY NOT THE MOST POPULAR
BUT THERE SEEM TO BE A LOT OF
FOLKS WHO DIDN'T VOTE FOR TRUMP
IN 2020 BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T
STAND HIM.
IF SHE RUNS AGAINST HIM SHE
COULD HAVE A CHANCE.
>> PEOPLE TALK ABOUT GLENN
YOUNGKIN WINNING IN VIRGINIA.
HE WAS ABLE TO HOLD TRUMP A
LITTLE BIT AT BAY.
I DON'T THINK THAT IS
SUSTAINABLE.
I DON'T THINK TRUMP --
>> HE DIDN'T HAVE A PRIMARY.
IT WAS A CONVENTION.
>> AND I JUST DON'T THINK TRUMP
ALLOWS THAT.
WE WENT THROUGH THIS FOR FOUR
YEARS.
WILL TRUMP, UN, JUST KIND OF
STAND BACK BECAUSE HE WANTS TO
WIN?
NO.
HE ALWAYS WENT WITH WHATEVER FED
HIS EGO TO BE FRANK AND HE
ALWAYS SAID YOU HAVE TO STAND
WITH ME AND DEMANDED TOTAL
LOYALTY AND DID IT REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER IT COST A REPUBLICAN A
SEAT OR NOT.
>> HE DEMANDED CREDIT AS WELL.
>> WE SAW THAT JUST WITH THE
MOST RECENT ELECTION.
YES HE ALLOWED SOME DISTANCE AT
THAT POINT BUT IT DIDN'T TAKE
TOO LONG FOR A STATEMENT TO COME
OUT, HIM ALSO ASKING FOR CREDIT
FOR THAT ELECTORAL WIN.
IF THE KEY TO SUCCESS GOING
FORWARD IS GOING TO BE STRIKING
THAT BALANCE OF KEEPING THE
FORMER PRESIDENT AT BAY WHILE
ALSO TRYING TO GALVANIZE CERTAIN
VOTERS BY APPEALING TO CERTAIN
ISSUES THAT HE WOULD TALK ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S HOW RACISM
IS TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS, WHETHER OR
NOT IT IS PANDEMIC RESTRICTIONS,
YOU KNOW, THERE'S A QUESTION
OVER HOW THAT CAN BE SUSTAINABLE
BECAUSE AS YOU WERE SAYING,
YOU'RE RELYING ON A PRESIDENT
WHO LIKES TO CLAIM CREDIT FOR A
LOT OF THESE THINGS.
>> AND HERE IS CHRIS CHRISTIE
TRYING TO THREAD THE NEEDLE.
HE IS CERTAINLY NOT OUT THERE
LIKE LIZ CHENEY BUT ALSO NOT
SUCKING UP TO TRUMP LIKE SOME OF
THE OTHERS.
HERE'S WHAT HE HAD TO SAY TO
AXIOS.
>> INTO A BACK AND FORTH WITH
DONALD TRUMP, BUT I WILL SAY
THIS.
WHEN I RAN FOR RE-ELECTION IN
2013, I GOT 60% OF THE VOTE.
WHEN HE RAN FOR RE-ELECTION HE
LOST TO JOE BIDEN.
>> TRUE.
ACCURATE.
TRUMP OF COURSE NOT PLEASED.
>> YEAH.
WELL, IT IS A NEW TACK FROM
CHRIS CHRISTIE.
IF YOU REMEMBER, HE WAS
PREVIOUSLY SAYING THINGS LIKE AT
THE REAGAN LIBRARY A FEW WEEKS
AGO LIKE WE'VE GOT TO PUT THE
ELECTION DENIERS AND CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS BEHIND US BUT HE
DIDN'T SAY TRUMP'S NAME.
THIS IS A LITTLE BIT OF A NEW
DEGREE OF AGGRESSIVENESS FROM
CHRISTIE WHICH I THINK IS RIGHT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT ACTUALLY
I THINK TRUMP SUPPORTERS LIKE
ABOUT TRUMP IS HE IS DIRECT.
HE DOESN'T SORT OF JUST BEAT
AROUND THE BUSH AND THEN IMPLY
THINGS.
HE COMES OUT AND SAYS EXACTLY
WHAT HE IS THINKING AT ANY GIVEN
MOMENT.
SOMETIMES TO A FAULT.
I THINK ONE PROBLEM CHRISTIE IS
GOING TO HAVE WITH THIS HE IS A
LOSER MESSAGE IS THAT IF YOU
COME UP TOWARD 2024 AND THE
DEMOCRATS ARE LOOKING WEAK
ENOUGH THAT MIGHT NOT BE
PERSUASIVE TO REPUBLICANS.
>> WHY NOT?
>> IT WOULD BE USEFUL FOR
ANTI-TRUMP REPUBLICANS TO BE
ABLE TO SAY, HE CAN'T WIN.
>> RIGHT.
>> BUT THAT MIGHT NOT BE TRUE.
>> I SEE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
THEN ALSO CNN HAS NEW REPORTING
PEOPLE CLOSE TO TRUMP ARE
LOBBYING HIM TO STAY AWAY FROM
SOME RACES THAT COULD HURT
REPUBLICAN CHANCES.
A PERSON CLOSE TO TRUMP TOLD
CNN, QUOTE, THERE ARE ABSOLUTELY
PLACES HE SHOULDN'T GO.
I WOULDN'T PUT HIM IN MARYLAND,
NEW HAMPSHIRE, OR ARIZONA.
NOW, TRUMP WAS, WHETHER SOMEBODY
LIKE CONVINCED HIM TO DO IT OR
THEY SHOWED HIM SOME FIGHTS ON
TV FOR A MONTH OR WHATEVER, YOU
KNOW, LIKE BOXING FIGHTS, THAT
WHATEVER THE REASON, HE KEPT OUT
OF VIRGINIA MUCH TO GLENN
YOUNGKIN'S DELIGHT.
WILL THEY BE ABLE TO KEEP HIM
OUT OF NEW HAMPSHIRE AND
ARIZONA?
>> I THINK TRUMP HEDGES HIS BETS
AS WELL.
I THINK HE WAS VERY CAUTIOUS
ABOUT VIRGINIA BECAUSE IT WAS A
CLOSE RACE.
AND YOUNGKIN REALLY CLOSED
GROUND TOWARD THE VERY END.
IF TRUMP WENT INTO VIRGINIA AND
YOUNGKIN LOST THEN HE WAS GOING
TO LOSE A LOT OF STEAM.
THE THING ABOUT TRUMP IS HE
DOESN'T ACTUALLY HAVE TO SHOW UP
IN STATES FOR THE TRUMPISMS TO
SHOW UP.
YOUNGKIN RAN ON TRUMP'S
POLICIES.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT LOWERING
TAXES FOR CORPORATIONS BUT TRUMP
PUT AN ORDER TO END DIVERSITY --
TRUMP HAS BEEN ANTIABORTION,
YOUNGKIN HAS BEEN ANTIABORTION.
SO SOME OF THE -- IT WAS L